one of the ways I was going to tell you
to explode the living [__] out of this
Tik Tok live set up a Tik Tok shop and
go on Tik Tok for an hour a day and just
[__] doing what you guys do best you
will be flabbergasted of what's going to
happen here's why Tik Tok the longer
you're on the more they're surfacing
you're live even nonf followers
especially non-followers here's the best
part also then you get to chop up little
pieces from it and you run those as Tik
Tok and Instagram and Facebook and
YouTube short ads to sell the stuff so
you're basically creating a production
day to create good ads while you're
selling on a Tik Tok live it's crazy
it's [__] crazy